salut aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter
une true story une histoire vraie
quelque chose qui m'est arrivé je vous
ai déjà raconté comment j'avais retrouvé
mon mac quand j'étais à mulhouse et que
j'avais perdue dans un train je vous ai
également raconté comment je suis rentré
gratuitement à disneyland paris une fois
et aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter ma
plus belle boulette une bonne boule est
de bonne taille que j'ai fait en public
évidemment sinon ce n'est pas drôle
alors je vous le dis tout de suite je
vais changer le lieu le nom les dates je
vais changer un maximum de choses
ne connaissant pas exactement la
finalité de l'histoire je ne veux pas
remettre de l'huile sur le feu si jamais
quelqu'un dont mais sur cette vidéo je
pars donc en spectacle avec joachim mon
diffuseur on part faire chaud c'était
très loin de paris d'ailleurs ça c'est
un vrai détails mais je dis pas oui
c'était juste très loin de tarifs dans
une belle salle de 600 personnes ou la
salle est complète
alors tout ça pour dire qu'il était
complet c'est pas vrai mais c'est
important que vous puissiez retenir
qu'il y avait 600 personnes devant moi
qui ai assisté à ça dans le spectacle
fabien olicard avoue mentalist ya
toujours une personne qui est prise au
hasard qui vient sur scène qui doit
penser au prénom de quelqu'un quelqu'un
qu'elle connaît il faut que je retrouve
qui est cette personne pour elle et quel
est le prénom auquel elle pense donc le
hasard sélectionne une personne qu'on va
appeler molik qui vient sur scène avec
moi qui s'assied sur la chaise qui a sur
scène avec moi et on commence à discuter
et je lui dis moi dis que vous allez
penser à quelqu'un et quelqu'un que vous
connaissez n'importe où elle pense à la
personne j'ai c'est un petit peu comme
dans les vidéos de choper des signes d
information ce genre de choses et je lui
balance une vérité ce que je pense c'est
une vérité ce moment là je dis vous êtes
en train de penser à la personne que
vous aimez la personne que vous aimez
vraiment et elle acquiesce et oui
exactement
incroyable je suis sur la bonne piste je
cherche la première lettre du prénom je
cherche le prénom en entier je prends
mon bloc-notes j'écris quelque chose
parce que dans le spectacle je fais ça
j'écris quelque chose sur le bloc notes
comme ça une partie du public peut le
voir et attester que je change pas et
quand la personne dit au prénom qu'elle
pense je fais voir que j'avais écrit la
même chose en temps normal puisque pas
là
je note un prénom en gros disons olivier
jeu marc ollivier comme ça je suis sûr
de mon coup mais quand je vous dis je
suis sûr de mon coup je suis certain ce
père qui a des fois j'ai des doutes
des fois je me dis rh peut-être un petit
peu à côté ou des fois même le gros
doutes en faisant la gelée pas là je
pense que c'est très très mauvais ce qui
va se passer quand je râle je suis
jamais très très loin c'est important
vous allez voir j'ai mon olivier deux
marqué en gros sur mon bloc-notes et je
vais
quel est le prénom donc de votre mari et
elle me répond françois et à ce moment
là à ce moment précis je me dis elle me
fait une blague me fait une blague et je
garde le sourire show vraiment en train
de croire qu'on est en train d'avoir une
connivence et qui se passe une petite
blague comme sa part avec les
spectateurs rient un peu à mes dépens
donc je dis mais votre votre mari il
s'appelle comment lui s'appelle pas
françois sait si il s'appelle françois
il est là et là dans la salle françois
et lamont mon sourire je le garde
mais il est de moins en moins sa sert a
de plus en plus crispé parce que je me
dis c'est pas possible que je sois
autant à côté c'est sûr je n'ai pas pu
me planter à ce point quand même
françois-olivier ça n'a rien à voir donc
je cherche je cherche à quel moment
donné ça déconne jeudi mais vous pensiez
à françois là c'est au prénom françois
auquel vous pensiez afin oui oui tout à
fait oui pensez aux prénoms françois bon
écoutez je sais pas ce qui se passe mais
je suis plutôt sûr de moi parce que
j'étais vraiment vraiment sûr de moi en
plus à ce moment là je ne vous le cache
pas j'ai pas écrit françois j'écris
olivier toute la salle se marrant modo à
le point de se planter quand je me
plante vraiment je l'admets je les
assume et on en rit je fais des blagues
là dessus mais là j'ai pas envie de ça
parce que non je suis pas d'accord je
pense pas m'être planté et je vois aussi
dans ses réactions de visage qu'il ya
quelque chose qui cloche
donc je dis voilà j'ai écrit olivier
vous pensez pas aux prénoms olivier la
tafer non non pas du tout je pensais à
françois mon mari je vois un agacement
mais pas un agacement logique par
rapport à la situation j'ai toujours ma
peine je continue à creuser pour
comprendre qui s'appelle olivier dans
votre entourage que je puisse comprendre
ce qui va pas et là elle se redresse
elle se crispe elle croise les bras et
fait je ne connais aucun modifié c'est à
ce moment précis que j'ai compris ce qui
s'était passé
je pense que vous commencez à vous douté
j'ai fait une erreur dans mon texte qui
a ouvert à cette faille là quand elle
cherchait un prénom dans sa tête et
qu'elle a pensé un prénom un moment
donné je fais à la vous êtes en train de
penser à la personne que vous aimez la
personne que vous aimez vraiment et plus
loin dans le numéro je lui dis quel est
le prénom de votre mari puisque moi
logiquement la personne de qui allait
amoureuse c'est son mari vous sentez
l'embrouillé venir et tout sa réaction
corporelle et d'expression de visages
m'ont fait comprendre également qu'elle
connaît à olivier au moment où je me dis
je ne connais aucun olivier je sais
qu'elle connaît un olivier et là c'est
pire parce que ça veut dire qu'elle ne
veut pas admettre qu'elle connaît un
olivier elle aurait pu laisser de
m'embrouiller dira oui oui j'en prenais
là c'est ce refus catégorique d'admettre
qu'elle connaît cette personne qui m'a
fait comprendre
elle le connaît justement un petit peu
trop bien à ce moment précis j'ai
retourné ma veste
ah bon et retourne sa veste sur scène
c'est une expression imagée pour dire
j'ai changé de direction à ce moment là
je m'en suis voulu déjà et donc j'ai
tout repris à mon compte je dis oh là là
mais en fait je me suis complètement
planté j'étais à côté j'ai très mal
interpréter les signes au départ je m'en
rends compte maintenant donc c'est de ma
faute
j'aimerais qu'on vous applaudissent
bravo à vous est désolé d'avoir raté
cette étape là et on est parti sur un
autre numéro
toujours avec elle pour la remettre en
valeur mais au fond de moi je savais ce
qui s'était passé alors là c'est la
question que je me pose c'est qu'est ce
qui s'est passé dans le trajet de retour
dans la voiture s est ce que françois
son mari lui ai dit ah bon tu connais
pas d olivier notre jardinier qui vient
cette fois par semaine gratuitement en
plus c'est très gentil à chaque fois que
je travaille tu le connais pas j'espère
j'espère vraiment que j'ai pas causer un
problème dans ce couple là parce que
c'était pas le but du spectacle en tout
cas j'en ai tiré les leçons
depuis ce jour dans le spectacle je ne
parle plus d'aucune information
personnelle et je n'ouvre jamais au
global par exemple je dirais jamais
pensé à la personne qui vous a élevé
mais pensez à votre mère je sens entre
les choses sur des informations bien
précises qui sont en général plutôt
neutre et qui n'impacte pas la vie des
gens parce que je m'en suis vraiment
voulu je crois pas que le public les
perçu ça je pense que j'ai bien joué le
jeu en admettant que je m'étais trompé
moi
voilà j'espère que cette nouvelle true
story vous a plu si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir en
laissant un petit pouce en l'air comme
ça je vous en ferai de temps en temps je
le fais pas très régulièrement c'est un
peu comme ça me prend quand j'ai envie
de vous raconter l'une des choses qui
m'était arrivé
vous pouvez laisser un petit commentaire
je le vis tous et j'y réponds le
week-end à tout le monde je mets un
point d'honneur à faire ça n'oubliez pas
également de vous abonner à la chaîne
puisque le mental blog c'est quoi c'est
une vidéo par jour pendant un an donc
rendez vous demain à 17h ciao
oui